what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today and or season 1 episode 5 today
ladies and gentlemen if you can go ahead
and use the force leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated also special thank
you to all who have joined our patreon
page to become super sexy rejects over
there if you uh sync up with your own
copy for and or watch along with us the
full length reaction and we cover many
shows over there exclusively we're at
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch along is
included without further Ado let's swing
an action
yep
don't worry you'll be out there soon
Star Wars cereal
put blue milk on top you might as well
wear a sign that says I promise to
disappoint you
yes
shame we couldn't have seen more of each
other when you were flourishing Jesus
and you never call do you have even a
single Prospect before you
find a way hope what is it you'll be
asking for someone will take you on
Cyril alcohol will know what's best you
work for the mob now
so he's not trying to satisfy the Empire
he's looking for validation from his mom
he's a mama's boy it's all there
he'll ask me to have a look oh that
sucks
you know what this means don't you
yeah I saw your eyes go right to it
I was looking at his nipple they built a
lot of cages huh
the ax forgets what the tree remembers
damn that's a good thing get that
tattooed that makes a surprise and
there's Sinta Center costs
she's Stone Cold and fearless possible
love interest and the kid's gonna die
I'm here to win and walk away
wouldn't that be lovely so much to learn
my child we need to be going
oh change in plan dad's taking me I
don't have early class today get your
coat it's not up for discussion are you
serious go you're off the hook she wants
to take you the driver's waiting I've
planned on this and we're going you're
only doing it to show off
ouch
what is showing off
you're involved somehow
mother of the year oh my God it's always
all about you is this
restart the day I didn't choose this
conversation
tensions are high in the mouth of my
house
so appreciate the support yeah
yeah woman that makes these oppression
everywhere
Skeen pretends not to listen but I know
the message is sinking in Pace of
repression outstrips our ability to
understand it and that is the real trick
of the Imperial Thought Machine it's
easier to hide behind 40 atrocities in a
single incident Elemental rights are
such a simple thing to hold they will
have to shake the Galaxy awfully hard to
loosen our grip oh damn dude you're
starting to inspire Clem fight 4 and on
against I haven't typed on it yet I've
been waiting it's a work in progress and
I know that there's a great deal left to
say I call it a new hope
busy day can I finish your milk
I feel like I should be taking notes
right now it's a track launch so there's
an adjusted thrust ratio to make it up
the rep how would I know the weight
is this a test
it's a simple question and yes there's a
load clutch
there's a gate
just below what were you gonna do if I
wasn't here
I'll pilot no you'll do is you're told
I'm flying it we can taste your idea I
don't care but if it's my ass on the
line I'm pulling this thing out of there
and or you just earn your spot on the
team
target practice
everybody in the Empire needs the
shoulders back
more don't touch me you want something
you tell me can you walk like a soldier
now grab ander's ass
to even HR department can I be my
prefect
the title I know it doesn't come with
extra pay just get this up and running
before my next staff meeting
are they sleeping together I hope so
okay get the vibe that they are it's
gonna be a real rough one in bed tonight
let's walk it again you should switch
what why switch sides
skin is Left-Handed you want your weapon
on the outside
what am I right-handed center right
Namek
favorites right but
shoots left
[Music]
the switch
teacher becomes the student
what oh [ __ ]
that is terrifying it's gone
I don't think so
just one TIE fighter
God damn
so ominous so like Sky sharks
wow you actually feel that yeah
you messed up his hair
they'll soon see surprise from above is
never shocking as one from Below
I hope you don't die yeah I was about to
say I like you man
[Music]
foreign
like not even reactive towards it
many da needs to worry about anymore
though it's less than 100 last time
still enough to smell him right
it's my dude from Agents of Shield
forget about your business
I'll be making Ranch tomorrow night and
I expect you at your station so yes sir
something more to this Gorn
more
on the corn and door stop
issue
Niche it's hard
I guess the movie The 13th Warrior kind
of give Vibes to that
should he be wearing that around his
neck it'll be fine No One's Gonna notice
incredibly powerful kyber Crystal if I
was them this is how I do it I'd spread
it out never climb the same fence twice
it's too random to be random
two more files each
foreign
damn I'm not supposed to like them
I hope you catch and doorman
let's cancel this show early or maybe
that's how she'd do it because
eventually she's gonna help do it
salute what is that language you're
speaking
stay focused Clint
yeah don't get distracted by the water
and the build up to this one mission
love that shot to the Rebellion
just a few people around a fire
it's crazy this groups are waiting for
months to act how wrong
perhaps you'll study Uncle Harlow with
more energy in the future what field is
it he thinks I should be pursuing he
said
he said think about it he's gonna
strangle his mom he's he's gonna kill
her and become Norman Bates I stressed
that it was a large enough mistake to be
deeply educational yes I heard some of
that our conversation your side of it
hard to miss this is the most relatable
thing Star Wars has ever done
okay
you know
corporate officers and the Imperials
they're they're people too pen and corn
what's an imperial Lieutenant doing
getting involved with this
the Gorn is on their side
fell in love with a local woman lost a
promotion and he lost the woman
then he lost his taste for the empire
love always getting in the way of goals
and
evil totalitarian
governments
wow
[Laughter]
the thing you hear when posted to aldani
is that perhaps you'll be lucky enough
to be there for the eye but a film
around might be crushed by having
anything more than an essential roster
down here tomorrow night
uh-oh I wanted painted the day after
tomorrow I'll be here midday and I
expect to see it Shine make sure the men
know how close they've come
you know what Gorn you're all right
although that sensitivity might bite you
in the ass
this really is a beautiful looking show
Absolutely
great landscapes
rings of powers just around the corner
because you know what'll happen
there we go
great
uh he won't say why he's here where he's
from he doesn't say what he believes in
and now this who brings a treasure to a
robbery I just won what's mine everyone
stands down everyone
something coming there's a there's a
ship in the valley
mess
I'm being paid
to be here wow dang that's what it is
I don't want to walk in looking over my
shoulder
you knew this
the choice was take him or call it off
it just would have been something else
what's that mean the day before it's
always hard maybe you're the one that's
afraid of course I'm afraid but there's
a difference between fear and losing
your nerve
make a choice don't use me as an excuse
nicely done and or let's get to the camp
in one piece
you can all chew on it there
all of you
oh no shaking the man with the
ideologies and the beliefs
no I'm not mad I'm just disappointed to
Aspire for
oh sweet mothma family tensions
[Laughter]
when were you planning to tell me about
this New Foundation didn't think he'd be
interested why is that
that's charitable
you're right I do not give a [ __ ] about
that
wow what a Blade Runner vibe
[Music]
in the meanwhile in the complete
opposite setting
zero finally finished the cereal cereal
cereal cereal cereal
find the PS2 version of Android
I will find him she wants me to tell you
about my brother what matters is they
killed him Imperial prefect came in took
his land flooded it he couldn't bear it
so he
when the boat and fill his pockets with
stones oh my God I always hated the
Empire I don't really know what to call
how I feel now
so he's doing it for money too
that's right I was supposed to inherit
that farm that's as close to an apology
as you're gonna get
closing off
you got to pay me if you want apology
though tireman's in charge now I need to
know you understand that where will you
be if all goes well we'll see you
tomorrow night
I have a prediction about what they
might do for the future episode
prediction they'll do the mission
just scrape by
listening for there's nothing coming
through tonight they're either going to
be okay aren't they or they're not what
that's a daring prediction
it's never going to be perfect I wanted
it too much
oh man don't have doubts now it'll all
be over this time tomorrow we'll just be
starting
that's spirit
hey it's the Hellraiser box
[Music]
[Laughter]
well done cool
Gilroy family
projecting their parental problems onto
characters like Cyril and Monmouth those
Hollywood guildroys
all right let's talk about it write
another solid episode of Andor back at
it again uh yeah I thought this was
great I loved seeing
um every little bit of progression does
it show so much about the details and
just going in a little bit of more of a
microscopic level of what the characters
are going through and exploring the pain
and harrowing nature of every one of
these people and you just get there with
everyone all around you know I I love
the suspicion at the camp of Andor and
that everyone's trust is but also the
way they weave in and out there's like a
bobbin and weaving here of I don't know
if I could trust this guy but damn once
in a while this guy gives good advice
all that [ __ ] about the which gun
holding stand where that's all really
smart you see me you know what you're
talking about yeah and like I know how
to do the thing with the ship okay yeah
what would they do without it seems like
he's necessary you know so it makes
sense that he wouldn't just abandon the
guy and so I really I really think that
what they flesh it out to and how at the
end of the day like the truth hurts yeah
to find out like oh he's not even here
because he believes in the car oh I'm
just getting paid
um but who's the guy who who's all about
you know the word
uh nemec I believe is his name yeah
nemec
wow you really just pulled that name
didn't you it's not even on screen no it
is on screen you act like you just
pulled that name his name stood out
because I was sitting there doing my
John thing going on I knew I knew this
guy from somewhere so like and he was in
the Black Mirror episode as the kid who
had the rob the bank
never saw that episode oh well never
mind it's a good one though it's a
famous episode anyway nemec he's the one
yeah who really believes and has the
gadgets I believe nemec can see that
there we know there's more to and or
than the money we know he's gonna have a
fighting for real for the Rebellion but
it is kind of like that classic Trope
you know like Assassin or Thief hired
but then at the day might not even
accept the money yeah they'll give the
money to the great to further the cause
of the Rebellion yeah you know there's
something bigger and I like seeing the
progression of how he went from the man
who has hardened who do pushed away the
feeling of caring but we know that
underneath that he really does care he's
not going to learn something and be like
you know what I care it's gonna be
something that pulls it out of him and
we're watching that poll happening like
there's there's more to why he's here
than just that and and the way they
flesh out the cam characters are are
well done you know it's really easy for
everyone to feel one note but I feel
like everyone's got a distinct
personality and and I think the way they
write them is all really well done but
let's face it the real highlight of
Cyril and his mom Edie the Big Talk of
the day dude they spent an entire night
eating cereal together they went from
night and today with that cereal bowl
which I think was Captain Crunch yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure it was Captain
crunchy Mary's he was a famous general
of the Empire Captain Crunch she's an
Empire here it's had a crutch
Lord crutch
no the roof of my mouth
yeah they look like Captain Crunch Bears
yeah especially the blue milk and I I
loved just how well fleshed out they are
doing with Cyril because it's it's so
relatable like there's this guy who's
put all his he just wants to matter he
wants to feel important and accepted and
it's all God all this like family [ __ ]
that he's had to deal with from this
from this judgmental unapproving mother
of his who's just always made him feel
less than everything he's had to try to
and it's like he's forced into he's got
no other choice but he's got to move
back in with his mom is emotionally
abusive mom yeah and when you see why he
is the way she is without them having to
do like a whole bunch of backstory just
watch him interact for five minutes
yeah I know like especially for for a
character who started out in his
position I do think it's like a very
pointed thing they're doing of going
like no no we're gonna spend time with
who this guy is and why and I'm sure you
know he's he's got the fire he's staring
at the Hologram of you know D.A to
dandor and he's you know gonna you know
try and probably do something rash in
order to fix this but at the same time
it's like I love that at least up until
now all we've seen is this guy like try
to do his best and just gets stripped
down further and further by everyone
around yeah because every action he's
doing is he's going well Mama proof of
me though what the hell is she approve
have I distinguished myself enough have
I ever become important
and for for Uncle what's his name to
know Uncle uh Harlow to notice me yeah
it's it's like you can see why he puts
all his focus into this whole thing with
Andor even now he's just like this could
have been my shot when he's looking at
the Hologram this could have been my
chance to prove myself I thought it was
really well fleshed out felt very human
feels very East Coast it absolutely does
British or New York yes
you know some of the gruffest places to
set your movie and or show it's perfect
I think it's great but yeah no I I love
that choice and to see how like the
sterile lifestyle complements what then
becomes the sterile Empire you know
duties and and you know actions and
things like that like it's yeah I I I
feel like it's this show is done in like
a really wonderful job at at putting
character elements where you wouldn't
expect them and then really using them
to bolster the story well yeah and
you're also showing how they have to
become a unit and that a big part of
what can help this this unit on this
mission is a unified sense of trust and
belief within each other it's kind of
like they're doing a three-act structure
with this heist mission the first one is
like the recruitment getting to know
um getting to know our players getting
an idea of what it is the second episode
is planning leading right before it goes
down and the third one is going to be
the ultimate mission where I imagine
like all things start to come together
like with Balan British ISB officer
whose name I don't know come on John
pull it out
page it's on an IMDb page here and her
name is
yeah I pulled out of thin air because
because like what they're saying you
know at the end with Lutheran when he's
talking with
his boss
this is his associates his Sonam of
Sesame
yeah he's on the right he's trying to
fix the radio
but as he's talking with with uh her you
know it's ending with like she's like it
all ends tomorrow or starts and so you
know this Mission isn't going to go
smoothly and it's going to open up a can
of worms yes and also be telling like oh
man she was on something yeah the
Rebellion The rebellion's Happening yeah
totally and so it's going to open up
that door maybe and or's face will be
noticed and then Cyril's gonna be like I
know
and then finally Uncle Harla will back
off and then if it seems like a big
divide it's happening when mon Mothman
her hubby oh is whole family units
suffering he doesn't seem like he's
gonna be down for the Rebellion it seems
like a terrible guy I'm like how did you
end up together at all yeah because yeah
that whole thing I love that bit about
like I didn't tell you because it's
charitable I didn't think you'd care and
he's like it really did feel in that
scene like he was like oh yeah fair
enough I'm not really that caring or
altruistic of a person I guess smug
[ __ ] yeah he totally just oozes
empirical you know status and and ick
yeah yeah I mean I kind of wish this was
a big show weirdly I know like each one
each one absolutely makes me want to
watch the next one and what I feel like
may be happening and I wonder if this is
what you were talking about it at one
point you said you had like a prediction
of what they might do and then you
mentioned here moments ago this sort of
like feeling like the three-act
structure of the mission and we had the
first three episodes being the sort of
you know big kickoff into you know his
tangling with the rebellion and whatnot
I wonder if you know across these 12
episodes of the first season if you'll
have clusters of three and maybe you
might have characters actually die or
have the stakes raised in that you will
see multiple like ensembles of the
resistance over the course or something
like that I imagine what I was thinking
what they might do is because they
didn't at all show us what
Val Vell the the lady who's the leading
her dad and Sinta yes
played by varada sithu dude off the top
of my head you are so good at names
you're just a big white screen in front
of me for no reason that's a bounce
board but uh they didn't show us at all
what they're going to be doing and they
made an active point to be like what are
you two doing multiple times
shut up you guys are always going to be
here and you guys are Marching and we're
over here good luck don't worry about it
look on your mission yeah like what do
you why would you so I wonder you're
with us I wonder instead of cutting back
and forth between what they're doing and
what andor's crew is doing is we'll have
one episode dedicated to what the men
are doing and then and then another
episode kind of dedicated like kind of
messing with time like maybe it's that
thing where oh no looks like the golden
point oh no and then should we go to the
next episode and then we see it's the
women doing their thing and that episode
ends with them getting the men out of
the bind and then it turns out yeah
Cinema expectations really high if they
don't do it I'm gonna be disappointed
that's what I'm saying yep yep yep if
Andor shows up in the next two X
episodes consecutively I'm gonna be mad
that's my little prediction but uh yeah
they're humanizing the [ __ ] out of
Monmouth out of everybody but barely
talking Rebellion stuff
I'm fascinated and really enrapped in
what they're choosing to focus on but
every time yeah they they cut around
it's like you have the Andor storyline
which is kind of what you expect and
that yeah he's being thrown into
Intrigue and into operations and you
know there's High State he's the one guy
even says the stakes are high Skeen
I think I did pull that name
is he on this page I can't I can't pull
it again the guy from the girls show oh
is he on girls yeah I'm pretty sure
everybody being in uh that the woman and
from
get out oh yes
it's another name
no maybe
Miss Michelle something Allison oh did
you interview her
yeah no I did Jordan peel and I did them
together I did her and Daniel Kalia damn
I should remember oh I feel so bad now
never cool sending her this portion of
her friends no thank you for shaming me
to my soon to be anyway yeah he was on
that show I believe okay yeah yeah but
he even says that thing about like this
the stakes are High
um and then you cut to you know other
characters who are in pertinent
positions and in pertinent situations
and you know you have um Lutheran you
know fretting over the mission but yeah
when you cut to Cyril and you cut them
on Mothman like both of their stories
and both of their scenes and moments are
much smaller and more I feel like
deliberately placed and they could feel
random and I feel like yet each one
contributes to their characters and
while they don't like obviously progress
the main plot of their involvement you
know with the stakes with everything
andor's dealing with I don't know they
still feel like vital and like they're
insightful moments and I mean Vermont
moth but yeah it's like it's I'm sure
this personal wedge is going to play a
big part in her overall you know real
cresting into being like a figure in the
Rebellion well I feel like there are
elements of this that deal a lot with
sacrifice
and it looks like she's gonna be
sacrificing being a mom and wife her
shitty husband and shitty daughter yeah
it's hard leaving my husband but my
daughter easy
yeah man she's the one she doesn't want
to live to school I can't even hang out
with Mom for 10 minutes so yeah you have
that and and I think this is really
capitalizing on yeah the the sacrifice
and the toll that it took for these
individuals to the lot everything they
had to give up for this real life War
that's it I feel like it's just it's
what's the what's this life like for
everybody yeah you know is how it feels
and really nice which I think is great
and with that character nemec
I think is really interesting because
you know sometimes you get like these
hokey speeches in Star Wars that just
feel like cheesy as [ __ ] hope
yeah and and it's and you do forget that
a lot of times in in movements
you know there's
you know when I think about like I'm
gonna correlate Star Wars the Civil
Rights Movement here I go that there's
no crossover there sometimes the Malcolm
X
and Martin Luther were at odds with each
other because
Malcolm X was some would encourage you
know like yeah fight back yeah yeah they
would understand peaceful diplomacy we
got to take action to show our series
Martin Luther King was very much about
no no violence spread the good work
though you know and like this is a very
basic version
and and it's like when he was like
demonstrating is the thing that we
always see in Star Wars which is like
Rebellion fight you know figure [ __ ] out
even Rogue one just like it's about
fighting and there's the other side of
it of but how do you move people to
belief other than just taking action how
do you change philosophy how do you
inspire Beyond just action what it what
can you communicate what can you pass on
and I don't know if they're gonna do
anything with it but it's a nice
sentiment that I think would be cool to
have yeah and I like the way they
exemplified that through the character
of Gorn because when you're watching him
walk around it first you know he very
much comes across the part and then when
you learn why and how he and my
suspicions oh sure sure no you called it
but but at the same time I feel like he
plays the role well but of you know like
there are imperial defectors and and
characters yeah who come in clutch and
who are secretly double agenting for the
Rebellion but this was one of the times
where I feel like it felt the most vital
and it felt the most like instead of
just needing to have that kind of
character in this kind of story it felt
like oh I can actually see why
somebody's dedication and vocation and
conviction might change in this big old
structure and uh and yeah I don't know
it's it like it gives a fascinating
flavor to all this because I feel like
it's right at home in Star Wars but it
really does make everything a lot more
gray and a lot more muddy because we are
so used to being like yeah most all the
Imperials like have the same exact
mindset and they don't have any other
life other than this and uh and yeah
that whole thing with his brother and
all that and just like losing the taste
for the Empire it's like even though
that that is like an info dump it still
like reads very human
yeah but they they did a good job on
covering the info now yeah no they do
I'm saying she was like it's good stuff
she wants me to tell you about my
brother look the only important part is
he was killed and then here's a little
bit of information I'm like I was
actually taking notes my writing brain
was like clever way to get away with
just
flat out Exposition yeah no those
Gilroys man they're very conscientious
they're very smart writers
all right guys well yeah I really like
this I liked it more than the last one
um this I really feel that like the
chapters of if it feels like it's a show
like splip every three episodes
but it seems like there's a new new
specific chapter every three episodes
Like Comics and yeah each three is a new
arc yeah that's what it's at least is
the impression I'm sort of getting but
guys leave your thoughts down below what
did you think of this episode uh
subscribe click that Bell leave a like
hey let's end this with a patron
Andrew Hayes look Andrew if we were to
pull off a heist oh if she didn't watch
this episode of and or
uh if we were to pull off a heist you'd
be the guy I want to go in there because
a you could be that high personality
loud distracting guy who can cause a
scene
that would be a great thing to be
secondly if we need to like maybe crawl
through event you are the perfect guy to
send in there as well or a garbage
compact or a garbage compactor third
climber rope climb down a rope or
something like that or whatever that
thing is called where you hook it on
render your your belt to your hip and
then you just yeah like some kind of I
was like holy ghost you know what I'm
talking about it's in every High School
yeah one of those it's like a zip line
but it only goes up and down yeah you're
being perfect weight compatibility for
such an obstacle that you have to do and
uh also if we need to run and get away I
get the impression you're a fast little
[ __ ] so I can imagine that you would be
right there charging and on top of that
if we need some strength tackle down
some security guards coming our way boom
you're the guy dude so Andrew Hayes you
would pave the ways for us to pull off a
heist for Mondays and lightsabers
yeah Star Wars all right yeah cool
thanks Angie for being here for like 14
years man you've been a long time
thank you dude
[Music]